there's no time o clock hello everybody
episode 141 we're actually doing another
true crime not necessarily a murder
although I guess it could be we actually
were going to do this topic which is the
disappearance of Madeleine McCann the
very famous probably the most famous
missing persons case in modern history I
was actually gonna do it on the last
show that we did about creepy
disappearances I don't remember what
episode that was but I think we ended up
doing like four or five cases on there
and it went on so long that I didn't
have time to get to it and then the more
I look into the case it's it really
needs its own episode because it's a
really complicated case I mean [ __ ]
netting has its own series on Netflix
just in an 8 episode series about the
disappearance which actually like was
put up after I'd already decided to do
this so yeah so I actually ended up
watching all of that there's not a huge
amount of new information on that one
you know aside from what can be found in
other sources this is like a really
fascinating case because one they just
have no idea what happened to this
little girl where she went to but also
it's kind of it's kind of horrible
because it's there was this whole thing
between you know the British police and
the Portuguese police and what they did
to the parents and yeah and the horrible
horrible things that the media said
about the parents that people on Twitter
said about the parents that they're
still saying I mean they're getting
death threats and all this other kind of
stuff even though it's very very
unlikely that they had anything to do I
think it's very unlikely with the with
their child disappearing I'm just gonna
say that I'm saying you know it's not
impossible but I'm just saying it's I I
consider it
very very unlikely and there's actually
no evidence to suggest until there's a
conviction that there is no guilt yeah
and so you know and so that's kind of
makes me sad too because it's like not
only did these poor people have their
little girl abducted but then they had
to put up with like a bunch of stupid
chuckleheads on [ __ ] Twitter you know
accusing them of like killing her and
just you know yeah they should die and
all those back when the internet troll
phenomenon was new people really weren't
yeah Twitter is actually was only a year
old I think when she neared when
Madeline disappeared back then they
didn't know you know what troll was well
and Twitter is the worst I never
actually go on there it's like I post
the show I have a Twitter account for 13
o'clock but I just post the show on
there it just goes automatically and I
don't know like it seems like half of
YouTube is half of the YouTube content
is complaining about Twitter yeah what a
piece of [ __ ] that Twitter is I don't
really see the point have Instagram and
I never use it yeah so you know they say
that that's getting to be like Twitter I
don't know I don't think you can say
much I think you just trade photos and
respond to them or put like of them or
dislike them I think only like them I
don't know well you could pass tags and
[ __ ] on okay like people who started I
don't know it's like people have artists
I I don't actually I have a personal
Instagram account but I never use it
either it's like people are like oh you
should have one for the show because a
lot of people use that which they do I
know a lot of younger people use it and
a lot of people have bumped me about it
but I'm just like we should do it even
though I don't really know how to use it
I should but it's like you know it only
really kind of works as an app on your
phone and I have like old guess I can't
afford these pants these fancy
newfangled phones I have a smart phone
but it's like several years old I got a
couple of phones around here they got
that phone it's got like a company phone
yeah yeah alright I phoned I don't it's
not an iPhone no no what is that thing
is it a galaxy I have a galaxy galaxy
samsung galaxy but it's rip but mine's
really old I think it's like an s3 or it
I think I think this is like a 7 I never
use it I don't have phone number anymore
yeah you don't even have a phone you
just have a tablet I had a phone I just
started never used it for like 2 or 3
years and I said ma'am cutting phone cuz
everybody has me on messenger what do I
mean I don't I want to talk on the phone
I don't mind if people like text me or
like message me and stuff but it's like
do not [ __ ] call me I won't answer
man I hate that before somebody call you
you wouldn't even know who it was until
you answered yeah remember how dangerous
that [ __ ] was because just like I see
well yeah now it's like I see the phone
number I'm likely the phone of that yeah
even if I know it I'm just like no text
me do we have any shoutouts or anything
I don't think so just our regular kind
of stuff hey check out our patreon or
whatever right but we haven't had any
new one since we're recording this a
little bit early because I'm just trying
to get a handle we're just trying to get
a little bit ahead so this is actually
probably like a week or two ahead of one
this is gonna go up so yeah so we
haven't had any new patrons since I
recorded the last show yeah last one he
did was only a couple days ago that's
why I'm still fat wait it's only a
couple days later man give me a break
yeah so as I said we're going to be
talking today about the disappearance of
Madeleine McCann this has been requested
numerous times and like I said I was
going to do it on our disappearances
show that I did you know months ago but
I just didn't get around to we didn't
have time and like I said this kind of
needs its own show because there's a lot
of [ __ ] going on so famously Madeleine
McCann three years old she was actually
when she disappeared it was actually
about nine days before her fourth
birthday you guys don't know who it is
she's talking about look at the screen
yeah it was that case about that pretty
girl that got snatched
she's her she had an English parents
they
in Spain I think our ports cortical and
they put her to bed and when they woke
up she was gone but her brother and
sister weren't taken yeah she had some
twins and they don't know it never
didn't see that girl game yeah it was
like a big thing and we're looking at
that girl for a long time yeah or no
blonde girl how old was she
three I just said three well she was on
this for almost which she disappeared
about nine days it's almost kind of a
job but a ramsey type case except they
knew she was dead this one they didn't
days did no guilty yeah they have they
have never found her and there is
speculation that it's possible that she
could still be alive because maybe she
was kidnapped by some like sex
trafficking or something it has happened
before or somebody you know nabbed or
nabbed her in like she got sold to like
a rich couple or something like that it
does or you know she was kept in a
basement or something that's horrible
but it does happen
um so you know the the parents are still
obviously holding out hope that she will
still be found alive JonBenet case never
got solved either although you I have a
theory over that one we have to do a
show about that should I save it for the
show well if you want I'll save it for
the show but I think I know who did it
yeah I think so I've had a lot of people
know who did I don't think it's the mom
I don't know a great deal about it like
I'd have to look up all the details and
stuff just kind of dawned on me to an
opinion it just dawned on me listening
to the to the you know that whole case
that I'll talk about it will talk about
like I said that means it's full on yeah
and this one you know like I said yes we
we do a lot of true crime shows and yes
we give our opinions on whether we think
but in the end it's like you know my
opinion doesn't really matter I wasn't
there I wasn't like on the investigation
I can lean a particular way I'm leaning
a particular way in that I think that
this was a stranger abduction I really
don't think that her parents had
anything to do with this and I'm talking
about the metal McCann case not the
JonBenet Ramsey case so whether or not
you agree with that I don't know it says
it doesn't really matter like I said cuz
I'm not working on the case and no one
gives a [ __ ] when I think about it but
I'm just saying I really don't think the
parents had anything this particular
yeah I'm gonna get that away I don't
think parents say they do no I don't
either
so let's set the scene this was actually
early May
2007 now the McCann family which was
Kate and Gerry they were both doctors
and they had three children Madeline who
was you know almost four they also had
twins that I think were only two at the
time they were younger than Madeline so
they were going on a week-long spring
vacation to Portugal and they rented
this apartment in this village called
praia deluge and this particular place
which is on the Algarve Peninsula of
Portugal very very popular British
tourists in fact this particular area is
called Little Britain because of so many
it's not just British tourists but um a
lot of birds also lived there you know
have have moved their expats so there's
a lot of other British people in this
particular area so they go on this
vacation they were it wasn't just their
family they were also accompanied by
several of their friends who also had
children most of their friends were also
doctors I think one of them was a lawyer
so altogether this was it was seven
adults and then there were eight kids
and that included the McCanns three kids
so the other couples had five had five
kids between them so these were their
friends of theirs were Fiona and David
Payne these were also both doctors they
had two kids
Fiona's mother Diane Webster they were
they had both worked in the same
hospital with Kate McCann there were
also two other couples Jane Tanner and
Russel O'Brien they were boyfriend and
girlfriend they had two kids also
Matthew Oldfield who was a doctor and
his wife Rachel who was a lawyer and
they had a daughter so they were all
they pretty much had the the McCanns had
apartment 5a which is on the corner and
there's pictures of this all over the
place if you look at this it's called
the Ocean Club it was like a resort it
had all these um they were privately
owned apartments but it was like a whole
resort that was like a pool there was
tennis courts there was a restaurant it
was a bar there was like all this stuff
like in one area so you didn't really
have to leave that area
you know what I mean like very nice
place you're not talking about something
junky was nice yeah it was yeah it's a
really nice place and they had a lot of
these like around on that Portuguese
Coast cuz like I said this is a really
big like holiday destination especially
for British and German tourists yeah so
the so they were in 5a which was on the
corner and then they're up the other
couples were either in the ones next to
them or and I think one was maybe above
them like on the second floor so they
were all kind of like together now they
had been there for several days and May
3rd was the day before they were
supposed to leave now on this particular
day cuz they had got there on April 28th
then like I said they'd been doing
pretty much the same stuff there was um
the resort had like a little kids club
so you could drop your kids off there
during the day and they would like you
know do stuff with him and they would
you know play games or whatever it was
they were doing while the adults were
you know having tennis lessons or
swimming or whatever it was they were
doing and so they had kind of fallen
into this routine now the day before
they were supposed to leave which was
May 3rd they did the same kind of stuff
the kids had been at the kids club in
the morning then they had lunch in the
apartment and then they went and swam in
the pool and then at around you know
five six o'clock they took the kids back
to the apartment cuz Kate said they were
really worn out cuz they'd been playing
and swimming all day so Gerry the
husband he goes to his tennis lesson and
Kate like reads to the kids and get him
all ready for bed and everything like
that now let me point out something
though what's that they've been here at
this little uh compound this resort long
enough and they had a lot they were
doing a lot of stuff this is plenty of
time for somebody to see this kid and
that's okay and something else down the
rule they went there's you know
everybody saw this kid which I think
that's part of I think that's a clue
yeah whoever got that kid I think saw
that kid during that phase yeah because
I'm kind of leaning toward you know
spoiler alert I'm kind of leaning toward
the theory that who
ever took her either worked there or was
around there or was a guest there and
had seen her at some point I think there
was some and other investigators have
said this to you that there was some
quote/unquote reconnaissance going on
and there is reason to believe that yeah
oh and you know what what's that my
suspicion leads to leans a little bit
more towards guests yeah because if it
was somebody that worked there I think
this might be a regular occurrence yeah
we had a predator that works there they
probably get more than what I should
note that there had been a lot of
break-ins at this particular it's not
quite the same I know but did it broken
into three windows and a person who
would take this little girl was somebody
who's totally focused on taking little
girls yeah that's what they did yeah you
know I mean it's not a
spur-of-the-moment thing
sure that's something who's into this
this is a pedophile or somebody who's
gonna sell this kid yeah you know I
leaned more toward pedophile but I'm not
I'm not discounting the whole selling
her into sex slavery
I knew hard I know that happens but it
seems like if it is dance it seems to
farfa seem selfish you got to take a
live kid okay and whisk this kid away
and then get it to a place where you can
ship it out to another country and
there's people without dancing it around
here
it's boy this is a resort there's
hundreds and hundreds of people around
and the apartment where she was taken
from was on the corner it was accessible
by the public streets on two sides yeah
um so whoever took her apparently took
her out of her out of the bedroom window
which was right there like on on the
road kid nobody whisked away quickly and
kept in country maybe she's still there
I think that's unlikely or the kid was
whisked away and killed yeah and then
and then the body was done away with at
a leisurely pace yeah that's why I
hadn't been found but let's get on with
the story
yeah I'm thinking it's I'm thinking but
there was that reconnaissance period
like you're talking about yeah I
definitely think there was something
whoever saw that kid was watching that
kid yeah and and and watching the
activities it's gonna be a guy obviously
the women that have a
but it's much more it's more rare it was
a guy who was watching that kid and
liking that kid yeah wait that girl
looked in the way that girl acted
because that's what I'm going for
yeah that's what I think now what's he
gonna molest and kill the kid or was he
just gonna say that kid I can sell to a
couple in another country I mean there
is a slim possibility that could have
been yeah it could go either way but it
could go either way
yeah I think it was a sexual predator
it's more like I kind of think it was
more like and I think it was somebody
that was either like I said that was
around there and that had been watching
her or watching the other kids like
trying to pick one out I have a thing I
was I have a feeling it was either a
guest inside that complex or a guest in
another complex that was visited in that
complex wouldn't you have it yeah
because like I said they believe yeah
this wasn't the only resort there's tons
and tons rizzo if you see pictures of
the Algarve coast it's just like it's
all like holiday resort very much just
like all along this car there's tons and
tons of I might have been a foreign
predator and another resort he goes I'm
not gonna do this in the resort I'm
staying in I'm gonna do it in the one
over there yeah you know because you can
distance yourself but no one would
necessarily notice because there's
tourists coming and going like all the
time and there's public or walking
around all the yes you said no one would
really notice you were foreign I think
the Portuguese staff wouldn't ask too
many questions if a British guy or a
German guy was just walking around yeah
because they were just that was just
another guest yeah you know even if that
was from another resort it wouldn't
matter they because they you know they
don't they don't keep close tabs
security probably low yeah you know but
yeah so this particular um ice I forgot
to mention to that on the morning of
this particular day the day before you
know the morning of the day she
disappeared
Madeline reportedly said to her mother
why didn't you something like why didn't
you come when me and my brother cried
last night um which her mom didn't think
anything about it at the time but after
she was abducted she thought that was a
little weird because she then she
thought what if somebody was in the
apartment or what if she saw somebody
out the window or something like that it
just seemed like a weird thing to say
little kids say weird things
they do that's what I mean it's like and
like I said she didn't really give it
any thought until after Madeleine was
taken I think she's reading into it yeah
but I'm just saying that was like
another little clue so that happened
like the morning like when they were
eating breakfast or whatever now okay so
the afternoon goes by like I said the
dagger goes in plays tennis Kate takes
the kids back to the apartment and kind
of gets them ready to go to bed she
reads him a story or whatever now what
they had taken to doing they put I mean
these were little kids so what they
would do is they would put them to bed
like about you know 7:00 7:30 at night
and then them and all their adult
friends would go and eat dinner at the
tapestry now so all of their friends did
the same thing they all left their kids
sleeping in the apartments and then they
ate dinner at this particular table now
what they had done was that they had
block booked the table by the pool that
overlooked is was outside it was an
open-air tapestry ah so it overlooked
the pool and overlooked the apartments
so as the crow flies it's about a
hundred and sixty feet if you were
actually gonna walk it you had to walk
around the pool and like around the
street a little bit so it was actually
more like 300 feet but you could still
kind of see the apartments from the
restaurant you couldn't really see the
windows or anything like that but you
could kind of see the roof of it you
could kind of see over and like I said
if you know I'll find a picture but
there's there's tons of stuff showing
like what the view would have been like
and stuff so that was something that
they did they'd put the kids to bed and
then they would go and eat at 8:30 and
they had had a reservation saying you
know the last four nights of our
vacation we're gonna eat dinner here at
8:30 and we always want this particular
table so we can see the apartments from
there and then what they would do is
that one of them would get up every half
an hour or so and would go check on the
kids
you know either check on their own kids
or check on the other kids or something
like that so it's not like they were oh
let's just leave the kids in the
apartment and you know because I think
later on after Madeleine disappeared the
McCanns got [ __ ] on a lot for why did
you leave three little kids sleeping in
an apartment and you guys were over
there eating dinner with your friends
but I don't know is it to me it seemed
like not that much different than let's
you know what if you had like a big huge
house let's say you know like a 5,000
6,000 square-foot house you put your
kids to bed up in their bedroom like way
up in their room and then you and your
friends had dinner down in the [ __ ]
living room or out of the patio or
something like that and somebody crawled
up the drainpipe of your house and took
your kids I mean no wonder your house is
right up here that look like damn
shopping malls yeah no one would say
anything then because it's still in your
own house right but I feel like they got
[ __ ] on it's like even though it was
right there and it's like they kept
going back and forth and looking so I so
I I don't really you know I I don't have
kids so I you know I can't really say
it's like people like I would never like
I've seen I've seen European people do
some crazy [ __ ] by America's standards
like have a little baby in a in a
stroller and then just park it outside
and they leave it at the cafe or
something yeah yeah yeah I've seen them
do that you did that here they call the
cops on you well if you did that here
they would get kidnapped but that's
probably why the Europeans are not ready
for this [ __ ] over here I don't know
though we're slightly paranoid
I think cuz me and you grew up feral
Trail we did with it just whatever we
wanted yeah pretty much I was down there
and I'm sewers down in the flood control
system in California looking for those
giant ants from them yeah gasoline and
shotguns yeah yeah my brother was doing
that dude run around the woods
so yeah firecrackers no yeah ten year
old yes 12-gauge shotguns Wow shoot in
the place of a ten with a gallon of
gasoline that we'd steal and [ __ ] when
you were five you're sitting out in the
front yard drinking any Green Springs
Wow yeah yeah wait at the cars drinking
wine
yeah I had a mustache at six that's how
that's really testosterone all right so
like I said I'm just gonna say right
here I know that people are just be like
why did they leave the kids alone in the
apartment and stuff like that but to me
it doesn't seem that weird because like
I said they were right there it's like
you know they all they had to do was
walk around the pool and go in and pop
in and check on them so like I said it
wouldn't be any different than if you
had like a big huge house and you were
eating out of the patio when they were
inside sleeping I just I don't think
it's that big of a deal so what they did
the the bedroom that Madeleine and the
twins were in they were in the same they
put them in the same room um it had like
she was in a bed that was like farthest
away from the window and the twins were
like in little cots in the middle and
then there was another bed that was by
the window but no one was sleeping in
that now what they now the front door of
the apartment they kept that locked but
what they did was they kept the patio
door unlocked because it was easier for
them to go to the patio door and open
the patio door and go in the house but
they kept like the keys pushing the
camera the camera I said come here use
this show cop show it should look at
sleepy there she is what's up but yeah
okay so so what they did was they like I
said they kept the front door locked but
they had the patio door unlocked but
they had the the curtains kind of drawn
across it
so they also had the window that was in
the bedroom the kids were in they kept
the window closed the curtains closed
and the window also had like an outside
like a shudder and it had this thing
like you could pull it up from the
inside it was like a like a little
ribbon or something like that where you
pulled it and it pulled the shut her up
but then when you pulled it down it like
kind of you know slapped into place sort
of now there was kind of some
controversy over whether you know you
could only open the shutter from the
inside or you only open from the outside
or whatever but you know that'll kind of
I'll talk about that a little bit later
so on this particular night May 3rd they
put they'll put their kids to bed and
whatever to eat like they had been for
the last three nights as I said they had
with the restaurant they had had like an
ongoing reservation that hey we want
this they called them the tapestry tacos
right well not corn bread things with
little things with bowls
yeah well it's just kind of like a bunch
of different like it's almost like they
give you a bunch of like appetizers of
different things and you can like kind
of like put it on tortillas what are
they putting it on bread I guess I don't
know ok I don't know it's not popular
here in the United States moved for a
reason no it is it is I've seen it
around here yeah Florida if it's not in
Florida then it's yeah but it's not like
you've ever looked no good I gotta find
it we'll find it yeah I'm sure there's
I'm sure there's some around here I mean
I've heard of something it's worth good
know this kind of thing is she doing
film it film it do it don't move don't
move Pookie don't move ok that's some
[ __ ] down there music that's her laying
on the ground
yeah very alright
back it up sorry you guys alright so
they had like I said they had blocked
books to this particular table for
reservations the last four nights now
here's something like I said that makes
me suspect that somebody that worked
there or somebody that was had been
around the resort I think they might
have seen this because in the
reservation book for the restaurant
there was a note that said this
particular table is blocked booked for
the McCanns because their kids are
sleeping in that apartment or in those
apartments they want to be able to like
go over and check on them and be able to
see them and stuff like that so I think
that somebody might have seen that note
and Madeline's mom thinks that too so
she left a note that the kids were
unattended basically yeah I suppose well
they're saying that's why they wanted
that table and I guess they I guess
whoever wrote it down for the restaurant
wrote that down I don't think they wrote
it so I don't know that's weird
yeah that is kind of weird so alright so
they're eating and everything seems fine
now they as I said they would go every
about half an hour and check on their
kids and you know the other kids or
whatever so Madeline's dad Jerry he
takes the first check he goes about 905
p.m. he peeks in the in the apartment
and he said they all looked asleep and
you know they were all asleep everything
was fine he said the only thing that was
unusual was that he thought that he had
left the bedroom door mostly closed like
it was still kind of a jar but he mostly
left it closed but he said when he went
back it was slightly it was open
slightly more than he thought that he
had left it but other than that
everything looked alright like everyone
was still there you know
everything so then one of the other
members of the tapestry and Hanner now
she left the restaurant at about 9:00
o'clock because she's gonna go check on
her own kids now while she's going over
there she sees Gerry McCann who's
talking to somebody else some other
guests that he knew there and so she
passed him she
said that she saw a man carrying a
little girl who looked like she was
asleep that had pink pajamas on
bare feet stuff like that now she said
that he she kind of described him but
she didn't see his face I mean obviously
she didn't think anything of it at the
time she just thought it was some guy
carrying a kid because see here's the
thing the Ocean Club this resort it had
what they call the night crash which you
know you could leave your kids there and
there was babysitters which again that
was why a lot of people like freaked out
about why did you leave the kids alone
in their apartment when they had you
know a place where you could take kids
to leave them at night there where
someone would watch them you know what
I'm I don't know why they're acting that
way because it sounds like these parents
are doing the same thing all the other
parents are doing right they're there
with their kids they're all ready to
have a good time sometimes the kids stab
them nothing the apartment some of them
stay whoever saw these kids saw him in
the day yeah along with everybody else's
kids when they were down at the pool
yeah I think and he just knew what they
were that they were gonna end up doing
them basically the same things that the
other parents were doing him you know
this so he he knew that there'd be a
routine yeah he knew that the kids would
be by themselves eventually yeah so he
was just kind of time it right that's
that's that's what I'm seeing yeah you
know I mean it didn't have anything do
it child neglect yeah he could have done
it to any of the families yeah we're
there just that he chose that one well
and probably he might have even chosen
that one either because he chose her
specifically or because that apartment
was the one that was on the corner and
it was the easiest to get into without
being seen one event that might be
several things because you could
approach it from the street without
having to like cross in front of the
other apartments you know it might have
been I like that one and oh she's in
that apartment yeah I can get her in the
corner yeah yeah because the window
faced the street that's what probably
what it was yeah so as I said no Jason
were targeted there's probably very
little they could do to prevent it yes
they were to actually just leave yeah
yeah I mean how would they know yeah you
will may want to yeah if somebody wants
that kid done there are certain
situations like that don't get them yeah
that's what I mean hindsight is 20/20
you know it's it's horrible to say that
but it's like I feel like there wasn't
anything they could have done
differently if somebody wanted
that little girl they would have they
would have got her he's would have
waited for an another opportunity yeah
which that's a I think something wants
to steal your car they'll get it yeah
yeah but yes so so Jane Tanner said
later on after you know after the
disappearance and everything like that
she said dad around 9:15 she had seen
this guy and he was carrying a little
kid and I said it wasn't that far from
Madeline's bedroom and he was heading
east away from the front of their
apartment which was 5a now she thought
she liked that he looked like he had
dark hair about he was a white guy but
sort of Mediterranean looking about five
foot seven 35 to 40 years old wearing
beige trousers and a dark jacket and
carrying a little girl with kind of pink
pajamas with little ruffles on the
ankles and you know the girl had bared
had bare feet and she looked like she
was asleep and I was toddler II just
that change does it check out now here's
the thing though this was um kind of
considered a big deal at the time like
the Portuguese police thought this was a
big deal because at first they thought
that maybe she had been taken by this
guy named Robert Murat who was who was a
Brit and he lived right around there it
was only about a hundred fifty yards
from the apartment where they lived and
they said well this guy looked like he
was walking toward that apartment even
though that description didn't really
fit that guy because Robert Murat was
actually on the Netflix documentary
extensively like they talked to him for
a long time he had lived in Portugal for
quite a while him and his mother lived
there and you know he but he was taken
in they said he was a pedophile and all
this other kind of stuff but in the end
they had to clear him and what ended up
happening was that when the
investigation was reopened by Scotland
Yard in 2013 they actually found the guy
who that was who she saw okay and that
was his daughter okay he had picked her
up from the night crash and was cashed
she was asleep so he was carrying her
back home right Erin so yes so they're
pretty sure they know who that guy was
and that that wasn't the kidnapper but
that kind of
the fact that she said that she saw this
person and he was heading that it kind
of like [ __ ] up the investigation a
little bit because they thought that she
was kidnapped like earlier than she was
actually kidnapped you know what I mean
because this was 9:15 so there was that
whole thing now there was another
sighting and this one is actually more
promising now this was I believe they
were an Irish couple their name where
Martin and Mary Smith now around 10
o'clock they said that they saw a guy
about five hundred yards from the
McCanns apartment and he was walking
away from the Ocean Club and toward the
beach and he was carrying a three to
four year old girl and he looked like
uncomfortable like he wasn't used to
carrying a kid they said that that
struck them is very strange
they said he he was about mid-30s about
5/8 slim to normal build short brown
hair wearing beige trousers or cream
trousers they said that he didn't look
like a tourist like he looked like
someone from around there so they think
that this is maybe a more promising
sighting because 9:15 they said that was
probably too early so so there was that
whole thing now let's go back a little
bit to 9:30 now Madeline's mother Kate
she was supposed to take the next check
which was at 9:30 but she stands up to
do it and then one of their one of their
friends Matthew Oldfield
he says oh you know I'll look at on your
kids when I go check on my kids because
his they were staying just like right
next door just one down or something
like that so she said fine
so he peeks into the house now he sees
that the bedroom door the kids bedroom
door is standing wide open but he
doesn't look far enough in there to see
if anyone's in there so Madelyn could
have been gone at this point but they're
not really sure because Gerry McCann
also said that the door was open but he
said that he closed it back but not all
the way just kind of like you know
closer till it was ajar now he like I
said Matthew Oldfield he peeks in he
sees the doors wide open but he doesn't
hear anything and he doesn't you know
see anything unusual so he goes back and
tells them that every
is fine now ten o'clock comes around and
Kate Madeline's mother now she says well
well okay I'm gonna take this check so
she goes through the patio door at the
back which as I said has been left
unlocked and she also notices that the
kids bedroom door is wide open now she
goes to close it and it pulls shut like
like a draft so she kind of freaks out
and she opens the door and she sees that
the window and the shutter are wide open
also and that Madeline is gone now
her little blanket and her little she
had a little stuffed toy that named
cuddle cat which was like a little pink
kitty cat and that was still there but
Madeline was gone
the twins were still asleep in the same
room but the window was wide open the
shutter was wide open and Madeline was
gone so Kate understandably flips the
[ __ ] out she's running around the
apartment like looking for her she can't
find her and then she starts running
back toward the restaurant and she says
Madeline's gone someone's taken her now
forgot there on the first floor of the
second floor this is the ground floor
okay so somebody could have gone up to
the window and opened it and god I only
got out yeah
now as I said because she said someone's
taken her Portuguese police thought that
was suspicious because they were like
how would she know that it's like you
know bla bla bla
they also said why did you run off and
leave the twins in the apartment when
you could have just called from your
cell phone
why didn't you this why didn't you that
but I mean she just noticed that her
little girl was ashamed so she probably
freaked out and she wasn't you know not
really thinking all that clearly I would
imagine so I'm not gonna get too you
know
bother about that one thing that could
have happened is that that little girl
woke up and the parents weren't there
and she opened up the window was yelling
out and then walked out maybe the front
door well they did consider that but
they said here's the thing for that to a
happened one the window and the shutter
were very difficult to open and she was
only four right yeah also if she had
left the front door was locked so they
didn't think she would be able to have
gone out that way even if she'd gone out
the patio door they said to the patio
door was closed it was unlocked but it
also had a curtain across it so it's
like she would have had to open the
curtain open the door closed the curtain
closed the door and also there was like
a gate on the patio and there was
another gate like down by the street so
she would have had to open that open
that they did consider the possibility
that she had woken up and had wandered
off on her own and then had either been
taken by somebody just happening by
which seems a little far-fetched or had
accidentally fallen into like there was
some roadwork and construction and you
know there were some ditches and things
like that so they did consider that
possibility and then they did like look
around there but they couldn't find her
yeah I did that at around that age about
five yeah yeah I got out of bed just
walked out walked down the street yeah
yeah neighbors saw me though why did you
do it
I don't know hey were you going walking
down the street yeah like 9 o'clock at
night like I know she grabbed me took me
back home there's a neighbor that's good
she's finally walking around got out of
bed started walking down the street
that's what you do yeah you know it's
probably kind of like sleepwalking hey
man yeah I remember much about it and
I'm saying I'm not saying that that's
impossible in this situation um I just
think that because of the way it was
found since the back door was still
closed and the curtain was still drawn
and everything like that seems unlikely
that she would have because if she had
gone out the patio door then the curtain
would still be open right I mean you
would think she would think to pull it
back closed and and the gates were still
closed so it just seems not that likely
that she wandered off on her own yeah
and like I said the window and the
shutter were open and I don't think she
would have been able to little to open
those I think yeah so they star
I mean that they did like put the put
the alarm out very quickly they started
the police came at 10:30 they the resort
started they have a missing-child
protocol you know where they try to you
know find out where they did everybody
went to look for them now they had um
the you know the Portuguese police came
the policia Jim Judas Siara Judas yara
pj is what they call them they showed up
about 1 a.m. now they got criticized for
this but they said ok well it took them
until about 3:00 in the morning
to secure the apartment but the thing is
that at first they were just trying to
find the little girl
so they were just like running around
the apartment like looking everywhere
around the apartment looking around so
they weren't really treating it at first
as though it had been an abduction yeah
just yeah they were at first operating
that she probably just wandered off and
they were just looking to see if they
could find her so you know they [ __ ]
up some [ __ ] later on but I'm not gonna
ding him for that because you know at
first they were just concentrating on
finding her they weren't like
necessarily treating it like a crime
scene or like an abduction or anything
like that
so you know I'm not gonna get too
bothered about them not locking it down
even though you know so many people had
gone through the apartment by the time
that they did make it a crime scene that
at that stage there was really I mean
the evidence that they found there was
pretty much useless because so many cops
had been through there and other things
too now they did get criticized later on
for doing [ __ ] like you know dusting for
fingerprints without wearing gloves and
like you know things like that and as I
said there's still a lot of hostility
between the British police and the
Portuguese police and you know you could
kind of see some of that in the Netflix
documentary where I think the Portuguese
police thought that the Brits kind of
came in there they complained that they
were acting
like a quote-unquote colonial power
because they just came in like making
fun of them and like how they were doing
everything wrong and making fun of how
lazy they were and all this kind of
stuff so there was a cinema is all kind
of like they were like butting heads
which is kind of sad because you'd think
they should have been working together
to find this kid but they really just
weren't doing that so well I'll tell you
what little kid could just wander out of
an apartment yeah and a predator could
just happen upon demand happen upon him
and the kids becomes a target of
opportunity yeah but it's I think it's
less likely statistically so Jessica Lee
if the kid just wanders off the chances
are he's not gonna run into some copper
editor yeah it's more likely that that
predator saw him in the day before and
targeted the kid and came in there and
got him that's what I think I think they
targeted her specifically um you know
like I said they and they did the cops
did search you know canals and they
searched all the construction areas
around there but the problem is one
thing they didn't do was they didn't do
a house-to-house search of the other
apartments or even the other like houses
and other resorts like right around that
area they didn't do that until much
later um they also didn't put up
roadblocks until yeah you're talking
about something big scope though I know
that until the following morning so and
Portugal I mean we're praia deluge is
it's not that far from this for the from
the border with Spain and they were
saying you know it would have only taken
a few hours to get this girl really far
away like out of the country and really
far away I mean they could have just
taken off and taken her so you know the
fact that they didn't you know close off
you know that they didn't close off the
roads or like try to find people leaving
the country or you know even do you know
stuff like they didn't issue a global
missing-persons report until later on
like it took like five days for them to
contact intervene check to see who left
those resorts around that - see that's
what I mean I don't know if they did
that so in some ways I can see like so
maybe the British weren't just being
like snotty about how lame the
Portuguese police were we
it does seem like they didn't do some
pretty basic [ __ ] because a guy couldn't
target her whisk her out of there get
her into a rental car and drive back to
the European country he came from that's
what they're saying and it's like you
know there was no and it's like no one
because what they can do is they can
subpoena like CCTV footage of like
various cars leaving the resort and
things like that and they didn't really
do that until you know until it was
essentially too late because I mean as
they know and a three and a half year
old four-year-old girl chances are you
can keep her under control and in a few
years she probably forget her I forget
who she was I said it's my sad betrayal
somebody else might be raising that girl
is their daughter honestly it is shitty
as it sounds but that's probably the
best possible scenario because at least
then she'd still be alive and taking
care of you know even though that's
shitty and she really should be returned
to happened before oh yeah um and like I
said I think that her parents it
casually hoping that that's what
happened in a case like that it might
have been a woman yeah as women have
stolen babies yeah true
to raise him as their own like I said
it's probably would be a lot better if
she was taken by a woman because we're
assuming as a predator might have been
targeted by a woman who had lost a kid
yeah true I said I want one let's just
like that yeah but yeah so like I said
they didn't they didn't check CCTV
footage of cars that left you know that
were around there at the time or
anything like that um so there there was
a lot to be desired you know they didn't
really cuz as everyone knows most people
know that know anything about true crime
but you know kidnapping or anything like
that it's usually the first 24 to 48
hours that's when you have the best
chance of solving the case or finding
the missing person or whatever and they
didn't really get their [ __ ] together
until you know a lot of time had passed
so they were roundly criticized for that
we doing on time let's see we're
probably we're at 46 minutes actually
yeah let's take a break break right now
and when we come back we will talk some
more about the disappearance of metal
McCann hopefully the kitten will not
make everything up she does that like
every time we record the show now she
just comes in here and she's like you
guys are not looking at me so I'm just
gonna like make as much noise as
possible like trying to get your
identity ritual for her it is yeah
[Music]
[Music]
what to him yeah you want it okay all
right the faceless villain a collection
of the eeriest unsolved murders of the
20th century volume 2 includes cases
spanning the years from 1960 through
1979 featuring such infamous crimes as
the triple homicide at Lake Bodom
the family Massacre known as the good
heart murders the serial killings of the
Zodiac Bible John Jack the stripper and
the freeway phantom the slaughter of
dozens of women and girls along the
highway of tears and the Texas killing
fields and the mysterious death of
suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts by it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format okay we're back talking about the
disappearance of Madeleine McCann from
2007 now shortly after Madeleine
disappeared and this is something that I
think the Portuguese police this is
something that made them suspicious of
the parents from the outset this is the
fact that one the McCanns were very
they're very attractive people they were
actually quite well-off people you know
they were both doctors and they were
also quite media savvy one of the first
things they did I mean there was a huge
amount of media not I mean obviously the
British press but also all the European
press really all around the world you
know came to Portugal and we're doing
stories about this little girl
and something that the parents did that
the police thought was weird
was that they started hiring PR people
to deal with all the media
and Gerry McCann was later quoted as
saying I believe it was Anna Vanity Fair
interview that he decided from the
beginning that he was going to mark it
Madeline in order to get the word out
there and hopefully it would make it
easier for people to find her which make
sense to me it does and it's like I can
see why people might think that it seems
odd or calculated or something like that
but this is their daughter and it's like
if they have the means the resources if
they know what they're doing yeah you
know why wouldn't you do that because I
mean you know the more people hear about
it in the world the more likely it is
that she's going to be found so social
media hadn't totally taken over at this
point either so you know you had you had
to use the old marketing media if you
wanted to do that so yeah I think it was
a good call yeah and I mean honestly
that push and the fact that they
actually hired like PR people and stuff
like that is probably the reason why
this is one of the best-known
missing-persons cases you know ever like
in modern history and why that little
girl's face is so familiar is because
they went on this big long media
campaign and we're pretty open with
talking to the media you know got media
in there and stuff like that now the
Portuguese police like I said they
thought it was suspicious one also they
didn't like it because they thought that
all of these media people being there
were impeding the investigation so they
thought it was quote/unquote
counterproductive so you know they
didn't really like that either but you
know the McCanns just said look we're
looking for our daughter so that's what
we're gonna do now what they first end
up doing they apparently had some money
of their own but they also had I believe
he was a Scottish businessman who was a
millionaire I think he owned Everest
Windows or something like that in the UK
and he actually stepped forward and said
you know I will fund you know I will pay
for you to hire investigators and media
people and I will you know help you out
with any bills that you haven't stuff
like that so he essentially became their
benefactor
because he just wanted he didn't really
know them he just wanted to help because
he felt so bad about Madeline
disappearing the McCanns I had also set
up a fund called Madeline's fund and
that was in on the 15th of May 2007 to
you know kind of just get money to you
know do various things and get them get
the word out there they also had their
PR team who would like they would
essentially like arrange events like for
the media to come to like they had one
where there was like all these balloons
released they sold t-shirts they visited
with the Pope they did they were Roman
Catholics you know so they did all this
kind of stuff just to keep her name in
the media and by all accounts it
actually did work because not only were
they all over the depressant Portugal
and Europe but the British press was all
over and they said all they had to do
was put a story about Madeleine McCann
on the front page and that newspaper
would sell you know 30,000 extra copies
that day they said even the websites of
like Sky News and stuff like that it's
like they would have you know the the
little tabs it said like UK news world
news and then they hold a whole tab that
just said Madeleine you know what I mean
this is how big a story it was and some
people have compared it to like the
death of Princess Diana you know how you
know media saturated this story was and
like I said I think it was a weird time
remember that it was very weird yeah I
mean we live in the United States and
and for when Diana got killed it was
[ __ ] everywhere he really was it was
like the American princess Camille weird
they're gonna have a [ __ ] princess
well it wasn't Leia Princess Leia
because I mean it was a weird time it
really was is it well it just because I
guess because you know I was 10 years
old like when she married Prince Charles
and it was but I remember seeing it on
TV and it was like this big huge deal
and I remember her turning up to see
Duran Duran and I was good I was you
know I'm really into Duran Duran and
[ __ ] that was like her favorite band and
so she was always going to see them in
concert and stuff so it's like almost
like I didn't know that much about her
but I was just kind of like over
Susannah but um what is she yeah
which killed I remember but um but so I
it was just kind of one of those things
where she's just kind of one of those
people that was always kind of like in
the background fabric of your life and
then when you find out she died like
really young like in a horrible way it's
just really sure even though you might
not think about her from day to day like
some maybe somebody in the UK would but
you know suddenly just she oh she just
died in something so there was a woman
Dane as a car crash it was a weird
period man that was the time of like
Michael Jackson being around and Kurt
Cobain and all that I was a couple years
out of the army working as a salesman in
Wellesley Massachusetts I remember
listening to damn Howard stirred yeah
and yeah and they would talk about that
that was a big deal yeah
but the media was smaller then you know
it wasn't didn't have to compete against
YouTube yeah and the internet you know
well I think the thing they could
control your mind a lot easier well I
think the thing that happened with this
was that I mean there were still and
particularly in the UK there was a lot
of newspapers and they had to compete
with each other so you know they
everybody was like kind of scrambling to
to put stories about Madelyn on the
front page and as time went on you know
there wasn't a lot of new information
about the case so they thought they
would just kind of make it up you know I
mean just you know just so they could
have new stuff even though it was 7 so
they want to continue well exactly and I
think some people that even wrote for
the paper said that it's like we didn't
really care if it was true if some if
somebody that didn't even know anything
about the case had something like some
[ __ ] psychic or something said they
had some dream about the case or
something it's like we printed a story
about that because like people would buy
the newspaper I bet you that drove that
family crazy all these new I honestly
cannot understand how they I mean I've
seen like some recent interviews with
that I watched like a bunch of
documentaries and Bart's than not the
Netflix documentary they asked them to
be involved but they didn't want to yeah
the price sick of it and they encouraged
all their friends not to do it either
but some of their friends did but they
didn't want to be personally involved
even though they did use clips of them
from other sources but when I saw them
like on Crimewatch and all this other
kind of stuff I'm like how could they
stay so sane and like so calm relatively
I mean they're obviously still really
upset even though it's been a long two
you know it's been more than ten years
since she disappeared at this point but
after all the [ __ ] that they have been
through I'm particularly Kate because I
think she was demonized way more than
Jerry was because she know she's a mom
and you didn't do momming right so you
know so no that's the day so they like
really attacked her like they talked
about she's too thin she's not crying
enough she's not smiling enough yeah
it's like they said [ __ ] like that it's
like everything they just criticized her
but she's too pretty she's too this that
the other thing and it's like you know
oh she's too emotional she's not
emotional enough it's like you know it's
you can't really win yeah and I feel
like she kind of got really [ __ ] on so
for her to just like kind of keep her
composure and keep our [ __ ] together on
him too it's just like that's kind of
amazing to me so yeah so there was all
this media storm it got like a lot worse
later on like I said especially after
like leads dried up and whatnot twelve
days after Madeleine disappeared the guy
I mentioned before Robert Marat who
actually lived in Porsche he was a Brit
but he lived in Portugal with his mother
not that far from the ocean club he was
made what in Portugal they call an Arg
we do' which is like quote-unquote a
formal suspect now he was pretty much I
think he was only suspected because he
had been actually trying to help the
police out because he spoke English and
he spoke Portuguese
so he was kind of helping with
translation and whatnot but somebody
somewhere I think it was some member of
the press thought that he was a little
too interested in the case or you know
asked too many questions better
something they thought that was
suspicious so they reported it to the
police and the police basically made him
a suspect so he generally wasn't he was
interviewed at length on the Netflix
documentary he seems like a very nice
man and it was kind of shitty what
happened to him as well he actually did
eventually sue some of the newspapers
later on he did get a settlement for
libel just because they accused him
being a pedophile and stuff like that
which there is actually no evidence of
they searched his house on May 15 2007
they drained his swimming pool they went
through his phone his computer all his
videotapes all that other kind of stuff
they searched his garden with [ __ ]
sniffer dogs and all this other kind of
[ __ ] also one of his they call him is
associate I don't know if it was like
his friend or like a business partner
something like that and I think this was
a guy named Sergei malinka he was
interviewed either on the Netflix
documentary or some other documentary I
saw about it - that guy somebody set his
car on fire and wrote follow which I
guess is Portuguese for speak yeah yeah
they spray-painted it on the sidewalk
next to the torch Paulo doesn't
necessarily mean speak yeah what what
can it mean follow you know literally it
means speak but in in slang it's more
like what's up huh like what's up well I
kind of think in the talk man what's up
yeah that's in this context it probably
means talk because okay they they wanted
hey like tell everybody what you know
about the battle and McCann
disappearance cuz obviously you know
something okay so that's what I'm
thinking that that's that that meant but
there was actually no evidence as I said
that either that either Robert Marat or
Sergei Maliki knew anything
malinka knew anything about the
disappearance like I said pretty much
the only reason they suspected him was
because he lived nearby and they thought
that he was too interested in the case
something even though he was kind of
helping with the case cuz he was
translating so whatever he was
eventually you know dismissed as a
suspect in 2008 so now his mother though
who also lived in the same house like I
said they lived right by the ocean club
she said that she had seen a woman in
like a purple or a plum colored blouse
and that she had been outside the
McCanns apartment the night that
Madeleine disappeared and that she was
acting really weird now she's as far as
I know this woman this is Robert Moretz
mother Jenny she is the only one that
saw this particular woman if other
people saw her I'm not really sure but
so I so I don't know how seriously to
take that so but there was that thing so
like you said it's possible that it
could have been a woman but as far as I
know she's the only one that said she
saw a woman hanging out near the
apartment now there were a bunch of
other sightings though of suspicion
just men hanging around the apartment
the same day as Madeleine disappeared
and in the days prior so as I said
before in the weeks prior to Madeleine
disappearing there had been many many
many break-ins at the Ocean Club and
other places and the people had broken
in like by opening the window and
climbing in through the window and
stealing stuff so the possibility
remains that someone was trying to
burglarize the house and you know saw
Madeleine there and said oh I'm gonna
take that too while I'm in here but like
you said I I kind of feel it doesn't
likely yeah now another interesting
thing that had happened like a few days
before you know that had been going on
was that several people at the Ocean
Club and in that area had reported that
there were these guys who kept coming up
to tourists and asking for donations for
an orphanage in this town nearby now
when they investigated later on this
town that they were talking about didn't
have an orphanage in it scam so yes so
they think that was these four I think
it was three or four different guys that
were reported by several different
people they said yeah they either would
come to the door the apartment and go
who I'm raising money for this orphanage
or this whatever and some of the people
they said were really pushy and although
some of them they said were kind of
polite and it was just come up and
raising money for the son the other
thing so that was reported many many
times and so because of that made police
for saying well maybe that was like
their reconnaissance kind of thing maybe
it was an unrelated scam maybe they was
trying to get money just for some other
reason but this could have been them
kind of like casing the joint
looking for like I said might have been
pedophile might have been you know for
whatever reason so as I said like I said
these were several several different men
I think there were three or four
different ones that were reported one of
them was a blonde man who several people
reported as being quote unquote ugly
with lots of pimples so several people
reported that guy and
was also a different guy that was like
dark-haired um as his ass didn't show up
we're looking for a blonde pimply ugly
guy yeah please report to your local
police
yeah couldn't be me no way to talk about
me yeah you know that that's yeah so
yeah as I said there were several
several reports of just weird-looking
dudes like hanging around there
some people said that they had seen guys
like watching that particular apartment
like the day of the disappearance but
well it could be but then again you know
there were so many people hanging around
because like I said this was a tourist
resort that yeah kinds of people so it
could have just been somebody standing
around completely and has never grabbed
this kid was fully felt fully
comfortable to do so yeah which meant
that they they thought they were unseen
yeah all right and that they were above
being a suspect that was something that
creeped in there with ninja skills and
got him yeah I don't think he may saw
this person if they were seen they
wouldn't gone in there that's what I
think and there's a good chance it was a
woman possibly although like I said as
far as I know Robert Brad's mother was
the only one that said she saw a woman
act I just Bondish I just find this [ __ ]
very odd that this body wasn't found
yeah okay although it could be anywhere
I mean it's Portugal and it's like no
one really
they didn't block anything off for
several hours several days so if
somebody just wanted to snatch her and
get her out of the country or take her
out take her somewhere else in Portugal
even so you have to do that very easily
they would never know where to start
looking or what if they dumped her in
the ocean a lot of times that stuff
washes up though though she was small
yeah I just think that there's a there's
a chance that somebody took that kid to
keep that kid yeah maybe I mean like I
said that's probably at this stage
that's probably the best case
Aereo that's the right live that's the
right age if you want to take a kid to
race for you well yeah and not the
righty and there have been there was one
guy that was on the police don't step on
that there was there was one guy that
was on the Netflix documentary and he
was saying that you know in a lot of
cases where the the child kidnapped is
that young um that usually means that
they want them to keep them um not not
always obviously um sometimes and if
they wanted to rape and kill him I think
the body would have found but have been
found real close like in a back alley
just walking distance maybe because I
think they would've been felt
uncomfortable really going anywhere with
that kid for any period of time yeah you
know I mean they just do what they gotta
do and kill the kid and then move on
yeah yeah it's got a weird feeling this
kid might be alive I hope she is I hate
say that you know in case you know some
of the family members are listening
because they probably have this [ __ ]
resolved in their mind and you know I
mean they want to just maybe think well
the kids dead statistically you probably
say that the kid is dead yeah there's
something weird about this case I'm just
saying you know what like I said because
she was so little and because I don't
know I just do feel like if somebody it
feels like what a kid that small they
would usually take them kids was little
the kid was pretty kid was knit but kids
dead body was never found
yeah this was in a very nice area yeah
okay man that's that's a perfect
scenario to steal a kitty you want to
keep ya know dama yeah and that like I
said that possibility has been
considered and I think at this stage
that even her parents are hoping that
that's what happened because you know at
least she'd still be alive at least
she'd still be taken care of um you know
rather than just being like murdered and
left somewhere cuz that would be more
horrible it was a kid from good genetic
stock it's a high class family of
doctors you know I mean it's not the
type of scenario you know where this is
it's like a high value kid if you know
I'm talking about yeah and you wanted to
steal a kid to raises your own child
that's the kind you want to steal and
like I said I think they even like that
guy from the missing and endangered
children organization yeah yeah I think
he was on Netflix I think he said
something very seriously
where someone said something similar to
that on the documentary that yeah this
would have been a high-value child
that's a shitty thing to say but it's
true yeah the people that steal them
think of them as think of them that way
so you know so it's so it's very
possible that she might still be looking
parents with good education and jobs
taken from a real nice resort it's
almost kind of like whoever stole this
kid was the same class yeah they don't
want a junkie kid never from the lower
class they want one of their own a high
class kid to raise as their own yeah
that's the word that's what I'm seeing
that's what I'm feeling
yeah I'm just trying to put myself into
the shoes of somebody who's stealing a
kid yeah and how you're gonna look at
that ya know and that's just what I'm
seeing I'm agree with that guy whoever
whoever it was but that's what I'm
seeing - yeah and I just find it very
strange that this kid's body wasn't
found oh that's that's kind of lining up
for me you know what I mean this is a
high-class resort with a bunch of
foreigners in it all right
the parents were doctors the kid was
good-looking girl good-looking little
girl full of what blonde and everything
yeah the body never found no signs of
violence on the other children they were
left there to live it's almost kind of
like somebody said hey they already got
twins yeah they can give that one up I
need that one they take that one I'm
thinking it might have been a woman see
they're focusing in on these pervy men I
don't you want to bet this is a woman
who lost a child yeah well like I said
at this point that's probably best-case
scenario I got a feeling a decimal good
it was yeah I got no proof there's this
much it's just the feeling I have yeah
this doesn't sound like
to me yeah maybe not I don't I don't
know we'll get it we'll get into that a
little bit later but all right so yeah
about a month later as I said now at
first the Portuguese police were
suspicious of the McCanns the British
police not so much but then it kind of
started getting to a point where people
started highlighting like
inconsistencies in their stories like
that big deal inconsistencies but you
know Jerry couldn't remember whether he
poked his head in the front door the
back door you know it's just little [ __ ]
like that you know cops do that's what I
mean so you know and there was stuff
about oh could the you know shutters
have been open from the outside or do
they have to be over from the inside
it's like you know the thing with the
window open and all this other kind of
[ __ ] you know so I don't know like so
the Portuguese press on June 30th they
published this article that was called
the Madeleine case a pact of silence now
this was the first case because I think
with the Portuguese police were saying
that they did that they were insinuating
or maybe they were just saying this
outright that they didn't think the
McCanns killed Madeleine on purpose but
they thought that she had died
accidentally in the apartment and that
then them and all their friends had
conspired to cover it up yeah which to
me seems far-fetched ish [ __ ] ridiculous
but okay I'm just saying what what their
what their feeling was was that these
two were doctors
you know Madeleine had said something
about why didn't you come when me and my
brother cried last night so they were
thinking maybe they drugged the kids to
get them to sleep and then they gave
Madeleine too much and she died and they
didn't want anyone to know about it so
then they hid the body for a while and
then they disposed of it later on and
then they told everybody that it was an
abduction that's comedy seems outlandish
and I have to say right here
the the main head of the investigation
the Portuguese investigation that guy
what was his name Amer all I'm emeral of
mammal whatever his name was
he they interviewed him extensively on
the Netflix documentary and he later
wrote a book where he put forward this
whole thing now he was kicked off the
case and he was involved in some other
[ __ ] like I'm not saying that okay
allegedly there was a case later on that
was unrelated to the Madeleine McCann
case where a suspect was allegedly
beaten into a false confession and even
though he wasn't there he supposedly
knew about it and he got in trouble for
that and kind of I don't think he got
kicked off the force but he for sure got
kicked off the metal McCann
investigation they interviewed him on
the Madeleine McCann Netflix documentary
and he seemed a little bit like a crazy
person allegedly I'm just saying he just
seemed like he really really wanted this
[ __ ] about they accidentally killed
Madeleine then covered up covered it up
and kept the body for a month or
something like that and then like later
disposed of it I don't like that no no I
don't either and like so it seemed like
he had kind of decided that that's what
had happened and then he just didn't
want to like Brook any dissension on
that issue because if somebody trying to
wrap up the case if you ask me yeah it
just seems really crazy so so the
Portuguese price is running this stuff
then the UK press you know the tabloid
press starts wearing stuff too because
like I said they needed some stories and
then they're just like making [ __ ] up
about the McCanns like all over the
globe they were all swingers yeah you
know they were drugging their kids to
get them to sleep it's like you know
they they had formed a pact of silence
about the [ __ ] show it's like why
that why it's like that that is the
stupidest sounds like to me is a bunch
of bunch of kind of mediocre policemen
who were under a lot of pressure to
solve this case and they're trying to
come up with some way of explaining this
case away yeah because they didn't want
to just say well somebody took him we
don't know who it is
yeah they did want to admit that they
can't with some clever [ __ ] like that
that sounds [ __ ] stupid as hell no
that's not what happened
no I don't think that's what happened do
you know and honestly okay now here's
some unseen person targeted the kid
and snatched the kid at an opportune
time and was able to get out there
without even being seen or attracting
any attention I'm gonna say it's a woman
yeah
a woman walking out of there where the
little girl wouldn't even be it would be
invisible yeah no one would see that but
I'm saying that what I was gonna say was
that the reason that this whole you know
Oh Madelyn died in an accident in the
apartment and you know they covered it
up and stuff like that a lot of that
came from what happened a little bit
later on when actually the British
police because they were kind of like I
said the British police particularly in
Leicestershire and which was where the
McCanns were from and the Portuguese
police were sort of working together but
grudgingly I believe that the Portuguese
police had given the British team like
an office but they really did not like
each other and it seemed like there was
like just constant butting heads going
on like I said because I think the
Portuguese police were thinking oh the
parents totally did it
and the British police were thinking I
don't think so but you know like me
they're like arguing about like the
Portuguese were like well the British
didn't even want to like consider the
possibility that the parents might have
been involved and you know the British
police were like dude we have like this
high-tech like [ __ ] where we're putting
all this [ __ ] in the national computer
database and all this other stuff and
you guys just have files and boxes what
the [ __ ] is that about
so you know they were just having this
whole like [ __ ] conflict the whole
entire time
which was kind of sad so but what they
did the British police actually brought
in to a cadaver sniffing dog and a blood
sniffing dog now these were some
interesting findings I must say and they
went into this quite a bit on the
Netflix documentary so these two dogs
which were named aquila and Eddie kala
Tama tequila tequila tequila but it
spelled different I get drunk enough
that's how I'm gonna say yeah that's the
dog's name right now yeah so Martin
grime was their handler now Keela
um she was a blood sniffing dog and what
she was supposed to do was if she
smelled blood she was supposed to just
like she didn't bark she would just put
her nose by where the blood scent was
and then she would like freeze you know
I mean that was that what she was
trained to do and then Eddie who was the
other dog was a cadaver dog now he was
trained to bark only in the presence of
the smell of a human cadaver and
apparently for nothing else because
that's how they train these dogs they
give him cocaine when they do it yeah so
what they did was they brought these two
dogs to the McCanns apartment in July
the end of July 2007 now this is um
let's see May changes this is more than
two months after Madeleine disappeared
so they bring the dogs there now both
dogs alerted behind the sofa in the
living room meaning blood and cadaver
they didn't find any alert city outside
or anything like that so they also I
think one of them also alerted to the
closet in the bedroom that Jerry and
Kate had been using one of them one of
the dogs also alerted on cuddle cat
which was Madeline's little stuffed toy
the dogs also alerted on the car that
the McCanns had rented but they haven't
rented it until I think three weeks
after the disappearance so I don't know
who had been dogs are [ __ ] up well
well here's the thing - and this is
something that only just occurred to me
while I was researching this case both
Kate and Jerry were doctors so the fact
that maybe something like a you know a
piece of their clothing or something
that might have smelled like a dead body
or blood yeah that could have been from
work well it because it didn't wash out
because dogs can smell does old dried-up
blood smell like a dead body no well
there were two different dogs in one fur
but if if if blood is around for too
long does it start to smell like a dead
body
get that dog off see that's right and
honestly the thing about it and even
that they talked to Martin grime who was
the dog's handler they talked to him a
lot of the Netflix documentary and he
was saying you know the dogs it's like
it doesn't prove anything
we just use that like as you know as we
needed further investigation like maybe
there was a dead body in here maybe this
than the other thing and another thing
too is that even though the dog alerted
on the car
one they hadn't rented that car until
three weeks after Madeline disappeared
you know and like I said that's why the
Portuguese police were all like oh well
they kept the body somewhere for three
weeks or a month and then later they
took it someplace and got rid of it
which to me it's like where the [ __ ]
were they keeping it I don't know but
cops telling stories yeah it just seemed
a little far-fetched to me but the thing
about it is that the DNA that they found
in the rental car was inconclusive in
that it could have been the DNA from
either one of the parents or one of the
other kids you know what I mean because
they all share similar DNA so it wasn't
necessarily Madeline's DNA it wasn't
conclusive enough to say that it was
metalist DNA so there was no even the
problem to is that there's a language
barrier some of the reports were
generated in English translated into
Portuguese and translated back into
English for the press and also another
thing - and there was a woman who she
wrote for a Portuguese newspaper where
she was at Portuguese newscaster and she
said you know they were telling us like
the police were feeding us this
information that we later found out was
totally wrong she's like they told us a
hundred percent DNA match
we found Madeline's DNA in the apartment
we found Madeline's DNA in the car it
was not true she's like I don't know if
they did that on purpose or if it was
just like a mistranslation from the
reports might have been a mix-up between
cops yeah that too so it's like she's
like but I feel really bad because she's
like I feel like I contributed because I
went on Portuguese TV and said a hundred
percent that's her DNA implying that the
parents did it and kill yourself part of
it what's the likelihood
of some parents killing their own child
having the body stashed away in the
hotel and then call the police and see
and the finality that isn't making any
I'm saying if you were gonna do that one
yeah why would you call the police - why
would you get media PR everybody
everybody was crawling up their asses
within hours and hours that's not what
happened they could not go anywhere they
were looking for the little girl because
they didn't know where the little girl
was yeah and if Tom you can get rid of
their body that's maybe they could not
go anywhere without a million press
people and police [ __ ] it's seeing them
if you saw like I said the Netflix
documentary shows like a lot of the news
footage of the time and stuff outside of
there because they stayed in Portugal
for quite a while before they went back
to the UK because they were cooperating
with the investigation and it's like
they're in the house it's like there's
just a huge like mass of press like a
rat they couldn't go anywhere yeah and
staff and witnesses saw the little girls
hours before they reported her missing
yeah time to get rid of that body yeah
that's what I mean so I just think that
we took that little girl I think that
the whole story about that is just
ridiculous
yeah and honestly I don't I don't blame
like the the dog handler or the I mean
there may well have been this was a
rental apartment wasn't their house
other people rented this apartment it
was a resort what they do is they get
dogs addicted to hair - it's a cocaine
all right and when they find cocaine
they give him a cocaine treat and then
they start putting the cocaine next to
bodies or then they put cocaine next to
blood yeah all right and they finally
weaned the dog off of needing the
cocaine just to target on they start
targeting on the cadaver they find the
cadaver can give the dog of the cocaine
yeah but there's problems with that
system yet I mean the dogs sometimes
they'll just signal on something because
it wants some damn cocaine yeah okay
well you know this is close to what this
is close
give me the cocaine yeah that's what
they're done and like I said there's so
much and I think even the handler said
this a little bit like or said something
like this like on the documentary he's
like you know the dogs this is just you
know something that's like will this
warrants further investigation it's like
just because the dog signals oh there's
blood here there's cadaver smell it's
like one that wasn't their house it was
a rental apartment that wasn't their car
it was a rental car they didn't even
rent it until three weeks after she
disappeared so I just feel like at two
and three they were doctors which means
they could have had cadaver smell or
blood smell on some of their clothing
which doesn't really wash out cuz dogs
have a really good sense of smell they
could smell that like much later on so
there's too many
I just don't think and and the report
itself which I read parts of in the
original English you know not after been
translated the Portuguese then translate
it back into English was basically like
we can't make any determination with
this it is too inconclusive yeah and
dogs
the dog could lie too dog could lie and
be overzealous trying to get the reward
yeah and it wasn't just and I mean it
wasn't just the Portuguese Press that
said this [ __ ] either I mean it's like
some some of the British press even said
you know some of the headlines were
corpse and McCann car you know car DNA's
mady's that was not true
dogs signaled behind the couch though in
the hotel room yeah
what could you hide boats out roast dogs
yeah and the in the living room yeah
that wasn't even where she was taken
from though that's maybe there was a
dead mouse behind there sometime in the
past yeah it was thing like that yeah
technically the dogs were only supposed
to be human cadaver bla bla bla but it's
like you know you don't know you don't
know maybe somebody maybe somebody
pissed in the closet man told him said
it was okay smell funky and then the dog
said yes umm here give me a coat yeah
maybe I mean it's possible and like I
said it's it just seemed but I'm just
saying the fact that the dogs did that
that really fed into the Portuguese
police go and see we were right you know
what we did say it was the McCanns and
then they invented this whole scenario
of how they killed the you know they
killed the kid accidentally and then
covered it up and and somehow they all
knew about it and I'm just like like
that would happen like you could get 70
your friends to go hey let's not decide
this let's keep it super
secret that we accidentally killed our
kid and now we're gonna hide the body
it's not your trip yeah that's that's
crazy and I'm not saying it's like yeah
crazy should happen sometimes it's just
very very very very unlikely I think the
most likely scenario is that somebody
was hanging around there saw her was
like I'm gonna take that kid yeah then
climbed in the [ __ ] window and gener
when I go and she knew when when they
knew that no one was going to be around
and I got a weird hunch it was a woman
it's possible I think was a woman that
lost a child that's what I'm thinking
well then she went out to try to find
the best child she could get and that's
what she saw yeah and I mean as I said
don't steal child you're gonna steal a
good one yeah no I made a few to keep it
is just that's happened many times there
been women have stolen babies yeah in
hospitals yeah I know so you know it
happens yeah and it's not reported as
often I make a big deal about it I think
it's women that have lost children
right after they give birth to children
you know I mean yeah they have weird
hormonal stuff going on
I think they sometimes partum depression
yeah I think they forgive them for
because it's well we're stealing other
kids and [ __ ] because they don't catch
him a lot yeah they catch us a cab they
don't forgive him necessarily you still
get in trouble but it's like it's more
understandable because you're not doing
it like a pedophile with - oh I'm gonna
kidnap this kid and then rape him and
kill him
yeah she's kidnapping it because she's a
large one and she wants another one I
gotta tell shitty but you're gonna
understand it more yeah well I think I
think you know there's there in real bad
depression and they want a kid back
right now to replace the one that they
lost yeah so they're not necessarily
they're not thinking rationally yeah I
got a feeling that something like that
happened I just got a weird huh yeah as
a possibility sure I just got a weird
huh like I said I kind of hope that
happened because she's still alive
because I would think that a woman would
have a greater chance of getting out of
that scene and not be without anybody
because I mean obviously it's always
gonna be more suspicious to see a demon
well I'll come by all the time with kids
I don't even [ __ ] think about well
yeah because you just
this is such a normal sight it's weirder
just like you know walking around if you
see a dude you see some people just and
dumpy clothes with [ __ ] plastic
shopping bags you don't even see them
then come visit invisible do you know
that yeah that's a CIA trick yeah mr.
[ __ ] carry some plastic shopping bags
no you will see you yeah just weird huh
yeah or walk around damn clipboard we
can walk around a clipboard and do
anything he's got a clipboard in your
hand these people think you you're know
what you're doing like you're an
authority figure did you know that well
I I see a person in the clipboard and I
just think they're in there at the mall
and they was like [ __ ] it so I'm just
trying to get away from yeah yeah so I
dunno I'm on the clipboard you'll just I
do notice them in the census like away
from them cuz like no I'm not doing a
[ __ ] but it's like camouflage you
don't see that person yeah you won't
remember them just an with a coffee cup
an account with a coffee cup and a
clipboard yeah you'll become invisible
protip yeah but yeah yeah like you said
I mean when you see a dude walking
around with a kid that looks more
suspicious than a woman walking around
with it yeah and that kid could be
screaming and kicking and nobody will
notice it well yeah because she's like
she's being a brat today today I just
got a weird feeling that's what happened
yeah just saying well yeah like I said
that's that's totally possible and you
know like Matt's mom said she saw a
woman acting suspiciously around that
apartment it's just I don't think a guy
could get out of there you know I mean
with a four year old and not be I don't
know it does happen I mean it has to be
at the right time what time did she
supposedly come out missing what time of
night was it um she was noticed to be
missing about 10:00 p.m. still are too
early yeah it would have to be like a
pre-dawn raid
you know 4:30 to 5:30 yeah and people
are asleep that's when you would do it
yeah I mean that's the dead of the night
a woman might get away with it though at
10:00 although climbing in a window
because that was open was the front door
open no no the front door was locked
from the back door was unlocked but it
was closed when they came in but the
window was open and the
so obviously whoever took her climbed in
the window and climbed out the window
I'm thinking or they climbed in the
window and then went out with her
through the back door could be a patio
that a woman a woman might tap on the
glass and tell a little girl to open the
window yeah that's her mom was calling
you type of deal in the girl girl his
window and she just grabbed her yeah
that could be two cuz that's yeah a lot
of kidnappers do that kind of [ __ ] it's
like Oh your mom told ya come get you
and a little girl might believe a woman
before she would believe a man yeah you
know I'm just saying you know I was you
know so I got an alibi I was here that
time you had I had nothing to do with it
just to see it in my mind trying to see
it no Mon that's and I think it might
have been a woman yeah I think so
it would explain why you know no one
really saw anything of why she hasn't
been it just explains a lot to me yeah
true wouldn't it wouldn't it be
something like the last time I when I
called original Night Stalker yeah I
called it yeah whoo that was that that
was a copy with a cap all right wouldn't
that be some [ __ ] it's a couple years
from now [ __ ] boom they find that
little girl this is a woman man I hope
they do find her yeah it's got a feeling
that a woman did this I have to say
though and it's like I think they
brought this up a little bit on the neck
slit Netflix show and you know a couple
of you lot have written a book about it
they were also on there we're talking
about this they're like they were kind
of trying to I mean I guess they were
trying to explain it because it's kind
of obvious but why the Madeleine McCann
case is so famous when like other kids
that disappeared from Portugal or from
Britain or something or like barely
remembered but everybody knows who
Madeleine McCann is I'm like one might
have been because she was a cute pretty
little white girl who disappeared while
they were on holiday you know maybe a
lot of people could relate to that um
also because like I said her parents
hired PR people and splashed her face
all over everything
you know and like I said why wouldn't
she do that if you had the resources and
the know-how I mean you want your kid
found right I mean that's kind of the
main priority so that's
you adieu I don't think this was a man
that did this that wanted to kill kids
if he wanted to kill kids he would have
killed those twins when he went when he
when he jumped in that window to get
that girl yeah I mean you could have
yeah he was a dude that just like
killing kids you would have killed those
twins
then taking that girl somewhere and
killed them or killed her right there
too yeah I think it was a woman that was
trying to replace a lost child yeah she
was like these people got three I'm not
gonna separate those twins though I'm
gonna take this older one yeah I like
this one they can keep those twins but
it was something like that I should say
though that after a while because
actually the Portuguese police kind of
didn't they kind of closed the case in
2008 which was like a year after the
disappearance in the sense that they're
still sort of investigating it but they
you know they they said Robert Marat
they dismissed him as a suspect they
just missed them at the McCanns as a
suspect but then in 2013 Scotland Yard
got involved and they kind of went more
along the lines of you know some
pedophile or robbery gone wrong and they
put out a new sketch of the person that
that Irish couple had seen at 10:00 p.m.
the man that was carrying the kid like
toward the beach so I'll try to find a
picture of it but they actually put up
the what they would call an e-fit which
I guess is like an electronic you know a
composite sketch of the person that this
couple had seen carrying a kid toward
the beach on that night at about 10 p.m.
they're investigating that individual as
the dude that took her so that's kind of
the direction they're going so unless
then I don't agree well like I said it's
got wenyard that right I mean and as I
said yes one person did report a woman
around hanging around there acting weird
but as far as I know that's the only
person that has reported a woman hanging
around there everyone else reported
weird men hanging around there and also
there was they did actually
pull cell phone records from that time
because they can do that and there were
these three guys who were all on their
cell phones in that area like right
around that time and they all worked
there and so they kind of were they
interviewed all those guys who said that
they weren't involved but one of them I
think was arrested later for breaking
into apartments at this particular place
there was another guy who I don't think
he was one of the cell phone people but
he had actually been arrested also for
breaking in a place because he had like
a drug habit and he was like breaking in
like trying to get money and he was also
suspected of raping little kids like
little sexual assault and stuff like
that even though his he died he's dead
now but his widow said oh he was
exonerated because you know the DNA
wasn't the same usually usually a
burglar sister chunky he's trying to get
into a window and find some cash or
something he can bond so he can get what
he needs I mean they're not really
interested in kids I don't think that's
I don't think this was a burglary
this kid was targeted yeah like I said I
think I think most people do yeah this
wasn't some work oh I'm just breaking in
and oh hey hey kids I don't hey little
girl company that's just doesn't happen
yeah now there was in March of 2014
Scotland Yard put out another you know
some more information about this guy who
apparently between 2004 and 2006 there
were four incidents involving British
families in this same area two of them
were at the Ocean Club the same place
and two of them were at other resorts in
pry déluge he was actually suspected of
sexually assaulting five different girls
little white girls aged seven to ten in
their beds so this is they're not sure
where this guy's from he could speak
English but they said he had a foreign
accent although I don't know what
country he was from he supposedly had
short dark hair tan skin
and three of the victims said that he
had a distinctive smell he didn't kill
any of them not that they know of
he didn't take him anywhere but he was
believed that they that he section if
that happened to this girl where's the
body
yeah that's what I'm talking yeah no I
knows the body I'm just it just doesn't
smell right to me I think they're
barking up the wrong tree I think this I
think this was I think this was a woman
but there were some people that that
were suspected yeah
similar sexual assaults of little girls
in their beds in that same area right at
around that time period so I'm just
saying that's another rise so it's not a
crazy process but they weren't taken and
they weren't killed and if they that
they know uh but they know up but the
thing is is that if this girl was killed
where's the body
that's the yeah but I'm saying typically
typically the body would be found nearby
and not even really concealed you know I
mean it happens all the time
usually it's within a few miles and it's
just you know out in a wood line
somewhere yeah you know not really
hidden you know well I think the guys
that dumped the body is actually kind of
water to be found
they just want to be seen dumping them
right you know I just you know they
don't care enough to hide him that much
I don't think so I just man I think this
girl might there's a good chance I think
this girl's alive being raised by
somebody
yeah it's and she probably has no idea
yeah maybe not yeah although like I said
you'd think that she'd be like no her
face splashed everyone be like hey
that's me
she might not recognize herself at 4:00
you know I don't know yeah I mean she'd
be a teenager now yeah and if you know
if she has a good cover story from the
mother that's raising her you know I
mean we may not suspect anything I don't
know yeah but what about her twins
they're old now they're they've grown up
do they remember anything no but they
were little and they slept through the
whole thing in fact they slept through
her being taken and they also sled
through most of the people running
around in the apartment like looking for
and [ __ ] like that they didn't so they
don't seem to know anything right but
yeah so later on and there's actually a
hole if you look there's a Wikipedia
page about the disappearance of metal
and they can there's also a separate
Wikipedia page about all of the reported
sightings of her after she disappeared
now most of these weren't investigated
and were found to be without merit
because somebody because you know like I
said you know a case this high-profile
obviously I'm just gonna call hey I saw
this little blonde girl like in a store
or something like that and they have to
investigate it obviously so they do most
of the time it seemed like 80 90 percent
of the time but they realized that that
was you know this person's daughter that
they saw them with and you know it
wasn't her but there have been sightings
of her pretty much all over the place
other places in Portugal there were a
bunch in Morocco you know there were
some in Spain there were some just
everywhere so there's a whole page of
those so I'm not gonna go into all that
but if you want to go look there's a
whole Wikipedia page like I said just
sightings of Madeline Mackay and look it
up and there's just like a whole [ __ ]
thing you know people have just seen her
all over the place as I said most of
them have been investigated and most of
them were not her but you know as of
this date it's like there's really not
any more information about it it seems
like most of the information that's come
out lately you know every time there's
an anniversary everybody wants to run a
story about it
so they'll kind of dredge up any old
nothing that somebody somewhere said
that doesn't really know anything but
that seems to be where it stands they
have no idea you know who took her where
she is if she's dead or alive and it
just seems like they there's private
investigators working on the case but
they don't seem to have found out much
of anything either even though they've
been investigating sightings of her one
of them even flew to Morocco to
investigate some sites and then found
out it was like some other kid I mean
man the case is awful cold I know but
you know
honestly it's cold but I've written
about a few cases that were way older
than this that we're solved um you know
what I mean and I feel like one this
high profile it's still possible that it
could be solved you know what I mean it
only happened in 2007 which was you know
it was 12 years ago but some cases from
30 years ago have been solved I think
there's a good chance that this girl's
alive
well like I said I hope you're right I
think this is a good and I'm sure her
parents hope that you're right I think
there's a good chance that because how
awesome would that be if it turned out
that someone had just taken her because
I thought she was pretty and wanted to
raise her and she's still alive
someplace I think there's a good chance
that would be awesome like it's not a
vibe this situation you know I mean it
makes me think that where it happened
victimology what does what the scene of
the abduction looked like you know the
twins were unharmed nobody found I got a
weird feeling that a woman did this yeah
to replace a lost child yeah and I and I
got a film that the child was targeted
because it looked like the woman she
seek pass it off as her child yeah
that's just what I'm thinking that's
just because she could get out of there
without caught without attracting
attention yeah and where's the body
typically the body is closed yeah I
never found it yeah like I said I hope
you're right but you know as I said you
know over the years because of the media
attention surrounding this case and the
fact that the media have kind of said a
lot of horrible things about the McCanns
without any proof the McCanns have
actually sued several newspapers in one
several settlements as has robert bharat
who like i said in the press was accused
of being a pedophile without any
evidence so he actually successfully
sued several newspapers as well so there
been a lot of libel lawsuits in
that whole thing also there was a whole
thing about like I said that Portuguese
investigator that originally started on
the case and then he got kicked off the
case
Gong cello or whatever yeah like I said
he trying to write a book about it I
think it was called the truth of the lie
or something where he was you know
putting forth his theory that Oh
Madeleine got killed in the apartment
and they try to cover it up and blah
blah blah
the McCanns actually sued him to stop
the book from being sold because he
wrote a book and it sold like a [ __ ] ton
of copies it was translated in all these
languages and they're like hey knock
that off it's like you don't have any
basis for making any of these claims and
they first won the lawsuit but then it
was overturned and then there was all
this others so they'd been like suing
each other back and forth like for ten
years because this guy's just and like I
said they interviewed him extensively on
the Netflix documentary and he seems
like a nut job allegedly I'm so crazy
he's probably making money with that
book I'm just saying
yeah he really really seems I mean just
that's a dick move yeah I just from
seeing his interviews on that he just
seemed like a tool yes saying allegedly
sound like he just makes it yeah and and
the scenario that they came up with
seems to me just way too far-fetched way
too far-fetched to have actually taken
place I just you know I just think the
simplest scenario is someone took her
and either raised her or killed or
killed her and then the body and then
dumped the body somewhere where it never
been found
I'm gonna say it's typical though when
that happens and that is very the
usually they're abducted molested and
released and found that's actually used
that's the most common thing that
happens a lot of people don't know that
you don't hear about that usually
they're they're like they're let loose
alive if they're killed they're almost
always the bodies found pretty nearby
and within ten miles if the bodies never
found some there's a chance that they
that they're still alive yeah there been
people that were abducted and then
raised and didn't figure out that they
were even abducted until they were
twelve
13 14 years old and I was remember we
were thinking well because we were
talking about the Ariel Castro case I
said man we should do a whole show and a
couple people have recommended this yes
we should do a whole show about people
that were kidnapped and then kept his
sex slaves for like 10 20 years because
there's a lot of cases like to stir on a
box yeah there's a lot of cases like
that thing is they deserve whole shows
yeah we should do yeah I don't want to
like lump them all together in one show
because they because some of them like
where she do the Ariel Castro case and
the girls like that that yeah the one
that like kept is what was it his
daughter kept her locked in the basement
and like fathered several children oh
that was over in Germany or Austria he
was Germany yes underground yeah like an
apartment apartment for it was all musty
raising his kids and [ __ ] yeah that
needs a whole show - that was right
there look like Dennis Rader's cousin I
don't know why did that not with your
own daughter that's unacceptable but she
would you would have done it with
someone else well of course you know I
don't have a lot of patience for Dennis
anymore in this particular case there's
a good chance that that was done by a
woman and and that this little girl may
still be alive I promise
well like I said I hope that's true I
think so I really do yeah but yeah so
let's wrap up this discussion of the
Madeleine McCann case there was like so
much I couldn't get to in this but like
I said if you really want to go to
Netflix watch the eight part it's an
eight part documentary you guys it's
like it took me so long to watch it yeah
you know it was a little tedious it
didn't need to be eight parts no they
should've been right for ya I feel like
they kind of stretched it out a little
bit I can see what they were going for
the director was like you know I was
trying to convey like how it happened in
real time like you feel some kind of
conscious right yeah it really did seem
like it didn't need to be that long
because a lot of it was like a little
romantic
paid his ass for eight so he delivered
eight so he's like okay well do eight
yeah it's like eight it's like eight
like almost an hour each episode is
almost at our 52 minutes or something
yeah I watched it although it's like I
I'm fascinated by that stuff wasn't as
good as the one about the girls that in
in the Catholic school that we're
getting pimped out by the cops and the
priests oh the keepers yeah that was an
8 episode so I think that was only four
or five that was about that well I wrote
about that because I mean sister Kathy
says Nick that was a good case and there
was like what a lot of people don't know
and I've read about this in my book they
kind of mentioned it a little bit on the
show but there was a whole bunch of
other murders that were kind of similar
that happened around that symbol like
Joyce Maliki and there was like some
other ones too that happened right
around there that might have been
related to the same [ __ ] was going on
Reese molesting people no that never
happens yes it does they were in charge
a whole Catholic school school they were
pimping them little girls out to the
cops yeah that sounds like some Alex
Jones level [ __ ] and it was really happy
yeah I mean that does happen on you know
like I don't I don't think it happens on
like a like nationwide scales but it
happens on small scale sure I don't know
man it folks awful weird well like I
said the Catholic Church their goods
it's kind of sad they're just [ __ ]
known for that right but I think it's a
big money laundering scheme really yeah
heard that they have their own bank yeah
so yeah think about it yeah they'd
launder anybody's money doing what they
do I'm gonna leave it that they might
have their own assassins just sent John
wick after my ass for talking bad about
it yeah they probably will if you're not
on the show next week everybody knows
what happened you know when I was a
church we always knew that the Catholics
for bad yeah of course it's a
Protestantism you know all those like I
said if they were really that powerful
every stupid [ __ ] on YouTube
that talked about that [ __ ] would be
dead so I wouldn't worry about it fire
father Guido Sarducci coming after you
did he die did that guy die is he still
alive I don't know it's like young
people have no idea where the [ __ ] is
that
he wasn't median it wasn't a real pretty
sense he was a comedian act like a
Catholic priest inspecting rose-colored
glasses in a cigar and you yeah try to
absolve you of your sins and say [ __ ]
what's funny he was from Saturday Night
Live if you look up father Guido
Sarducci I'm sure he'll be up there on
YouTube I'm sure he's got his on your
Wikipedia page yeah look up that [ __ ]
from old you know back in the cocaine
era cocaine and marijuana yeah
everyone's on the horse and the
mary-jane yeah everybody was on heroin
back in those days really where I'm
amazed that they are still allowed to
laugh
some of them are not sadly but an
alarming amount of them are I don't know
how they did it
John Wyden wasn't on heroin he liked
cocaine though he didn't say so but he
says while I didn't like heroin oh
that's all bull I like things that kept
you alert yeah there's a code word you
know oh yes well yeah well I can say
it's it's such a thing like we were
talking about this before but it's like
you know a lot of creative people have
you know problems with anxiety and
depression and things like that and a
lot of them will try to self-medicate
which is why a lot of them are drunks or
drug addicts or something of that nature
and I feel like a lot of musicians at
that time period I mean heroin was kind
of the in thing man it's like everybody
particularly in the British alternative
music scene and then the New York punk
rock scene everybody was on that ship
and honestly I'm like I said I'm a what
like look at [ __ ] okay I'm like a
huge Nick Cave fan oh my god he was on
so much heroin you guys and it's like I
am amazed he's still alive and he still
looks pretty fantastic even though he's
in his 50s well they're like [ __ ]
he's in his late 50s at least yeah yeah
and he's still out touring well heroin
makes you like a vampire you sleep in
all the time so you just kind of get
mummified now I always thought that it
either kills you young or it preserves
because look at Iggy Pop for Christ's
sake yeah he's like [ __ ] a hundred
and yeah it looks great
Steven Tyler same way it's another one
true but yeah see I always thought that
in the case of Sid Vicious you know when
you watch so I consider Nancy that
Nancy's belong and got him on heroin
dungeon sponging its belongin I was
under the impression that Nancy got him
on that and that was kind of like the
story but they you code her ass stay yo
code arrest that's not what happened he
was already addicted by the time he was
15 since mom got him on heroin since mom
was a junkie that's where that [ __ ] come
from I feel bad for said Nancy was just
like his mom I feel like Nancy got [ __ ]
on Jesus yeah she got [ __ ] murdered
man it's like in the in the photo
that's fine away but but even in the
movie like I'll as much as I love the
movie Sid and Nancy and I was talking
about this before it's like they really
made Nancy look like an annoying [ __ ]
and I really don't feel like it was like
that well some of the guys said though
said that what was her name
that girl the woman that watched out she
said no that she was actually quite cool
yeah
in a certain way but maybe in what
Vivienne Westwood Vivienne Westwood said
that she was actually quite cool well
she was a junkie too but she had her
[ __ ] together more than he's yeah but to
get on the whole Sid Nancy thing there's
no evidence that Sid stabbed Nancy yeah
all right that may have been an accident
they were quite terrible judge junkies
yeah they were and Nancy was the kind of
girl to stab herself in an argument you
know I'm totally of that and she was
alive for at least 24 hours in that room
with him before she died I think even in
the my haven't seen the movie in a long
time but I think even in the movie they
made it seem like she wanted him to do
it like she like goaded him they were
high they were right so so I even so
even in that movie even though it made
her look like an annoying [ __ ] what she
probably wasn't
even they were like there's a lot of
gray area where it wasn't just like oh
you [ __ ] and he stabbed her I don't
think it happened like that I think Sid
told her to [ __ ] off he was gonna leave
her and she throws a fit and stabbed
herself and then she didn't think it was
she didn't think the wound was that bad
and then they went back to shooting up
heroin in a fight it was just a small
and small little incision little
penetration and you know she was
bleeding inside but it took a long time
we will do a show on that I do she will
do a show on that on punk scene or
something well yeah like I think I've
been wanting to do one about that for
like a really long time and somebody I
think somebody asked us about it but
it's just like that that's something
that one I know a lot about it's like
you know I was kind of there read a lot
about it at the time and it's like
that's something that's really
fascinating even much John Lydon I love
that punk poster said he said nobody
knows what happened in that room yeah
heroin killed them is what heroin killed
both I would agree with that's what he
said
yeah I think she stabbed herself and an
argument in protest or something and
then she didn't go run for help
yeah yeah I mean so she stayed up there
with him yeah and I and then I think
they just thought it'd be all right
yeah I'd be all right it'll heal up yeah
you know then she died yeah he would he
woke up she he'd been dead for a little
while yeah so you know I don't think he
killed he didn't run or anything yeah
that's true yeah I don't I don't think I
don't think it was murder yeah I don't
know all right so let's wrap up episode
141 about the disappearance of Madeleine
McCann among other things not fun many
tangents as we usually do but remember
if you liked the show like share
subscribe on all your social media share
with all your friends and family
remember if you'd like to financially
support the show it would be much
appreciated go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give a one-time donation if you
would like to do that also remember
check out our Zazzle stores as well comm
/ 13 o'clock we have a lot of t-shirts
and
bugs and pillows and all kind of fun
stuff that you can purchase if you so
desire also check out my game crafter
store where I have giallo games which is
I have several different game is about
yeah sugar game right yeah that are like
based around I got this one right here
showing that big one all of them are
based around like giallo movies italian
murder mysteries that kind of stuff all
three of them are different so for games
you know ii mean you drink friends and
so check that out if you would please
also check out our last movie review
which was the 2018 movie upgrade and go
check that out if you haven't already
and we will see you on the next episode
next week
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]